first of all author James Dashner is
here
he created the thing you look at
director Wes ball is also here playing
Thomas Dylan O'Brien playing Brenda Rosa
Salazar Clank you know KITT okay good
you're coming under there key only as
new Thomas brodie-sangster and then as
far may jump Colonel Esposito
welcome welcome you guys uh so let's
just let's just of all congratulations
to you well done sir
thank you are you is it seeing it seeing
it ripped off the page and putting it up
on the on the screen is this is this
what you envisioned it's the highlight
of my career man just I'm enjoying every
minute of it
they do all the hard work I just sit
back and watch nice uh Wes you wet so in
the first movie you know it takes a
little bit of time before everyone
starts to figure out what's going I and
then it and it takes off but it feels
like you guys just like start right out
of the gate when I find about this one I
remember being here like a year ago
saying the same thing if we if we got
the chance to make the second one it was
just gonna pick up right where the last
ones to you know ended it was just gonna
be nonstop full momentum full steam you
know that this movie is you know way
bigger than the first one we get to
explore a much larger world many more
threats it's just as intense and
emotional as the other one so we're
really excited to see what what fans are
gonna think Dylan how how do you think
Thomas has changed since the first movie
um I think in this one uh you know for
for me Thomas is he's for the first time
I think feeling defeated
you know um and maybe angry too I mean
in the first film he's he's kind of the
one always motivated and like everyone's
sitting around doing nothing he's like
come on we can't do this you know and he
like discovers this leader in himself
you know and and then at the end of the
first film he's just crushed with this
guilt and and you know losing one
special friend in particular feeling
responsible for four other deaths as
well he feels responsible for these guys
and now Betty knows that maybe he didn't
lead them to the right place it's it's
going to weigh on him you know
yeah bros up what what did it mean to
you to become I mean I could see the
look in your face I've never you guys
I'm very emotional
I've never seen the trailer before and I
uh almost cried it was so beautiful it
looks it looks like the movie that we
sought out to make um and I it means the
world to me
uh this character is so fun to play
she's like a total rescue dog who ends
up sort of bonding with these people in
the name of you know getting freedom so
it's it's so emotional for me to even
watch this and I'm really excited for
you guys to see it
hasn't been for you so far key huh it's
been great it's a dream come true I mean
um you know working together on a movie
that you're really passionate about in a
story that's so well curated by Wes and
also getting a chance to work with these
wonderful people um who I call friends
and so it's really a dream come true
yeah can't really complain Thomas - what
where do you where's Newt at in this in
the second movie he's come from a place
in which he really knew how to survive
and live in this certain situation and
kind of grown accustomed to it
and worked his way up into the ranks and
he's um he'd been there for quite a long
time and then to come out of that into a
world that he has no power and no
control over and it's completely foreign
and new to him which is exactly the same
circumstances that we're all put in
really kind of switches up the dynamic
within the group and but still Newt
holds on to that thing of being the
constant source of encouragement for
everyone and and trying to see the best
in people and trying to get them
together to do what they do best in
order to make the best out the whole
situation and move us forward yeah a
sense of brotherhood was always a really
important thing to our movies basically
and angry we do we carry that further in
this movie I think Giancarlo Esposito I
don't this is gonna sound creepy I look
at you every day because I have a poster
of Gus fring it's a
oh thank you thank you thank you someone
did a depiction of Gus fring moments
after the thing oh it's been a while you
die I hang I'm you're holding you're
holding a teddy bear and it's this
artists depiction you're right next to
my dressing every day I'd see you guys
I'm half of your face in order to be
associated with such a great shown to
have the opportunity to do that and it's
a it's an as great an honor to be a part
of this film Maze Runner it's explosive
and I play a character named Jorge who
is equally as explosive as Gus fring
with probably a little bit more of a
heart this is a film that everyone
should be getting excited about because
it's not only about action it's about
humanity it's about family sticking
together to pull each other out and
believe it or not it's a challenging
film to watch it's so fast-paced but
you're gonna get the guts the glory the
humanity of this film you see it in the
trailer you're gonna see it on screen
September 18 I'm so excited
what I wrote what a block seriously he
is the man first of all we're all just
like nervous answering a crowd yeah you
told me every time well by waiting way
to keep me on track so guys lightning
remember when you were gonna bring and
then yeah I mean I just rope it in
someone asked me what role do you love
the best that you're playing I said it's
the role I'm playing right now yes Jorge
right now in this was not a casting but
Wes let's talk a little bit more I mean
are we gonna start to learn some more
the motivations some of the secrets
behind wicked and what's going on and
what what's behind the curtain
yeah that's the fun part about is we had
to kind of you know it was really
important to me when we first went into
this thing is we weren't just gonna do a
rehash of the of the first movie we
wanted this mood to feel totally
different you know we wanted to you know
just go into a whole new landscape and
and kind of explore new ideas and and
carry forward some of the questions that
were sore left lingering in the first
one and just continue this story so
what's really cool is that this movie
really does start exactly where the last
one left off so you could watch these
two back it back to back and it's this
awesome epic you know three-hour
adventure I mean it's gonna be really
fun I think and sort of still leaves out
some leave some new questions basically
and some cool new twists and turns are
going to kind of pop up not gonna give
those away but right there there is
gonna throw us into basically a really
cool third movie basically and it's so
when you're taking characters a lot of
characters that people already know and
they're very personal to people
what what is your role especially you
know when you when you're working with
Jane how do you how do you on how do you
honor that but then also give the
audience something new because obviously
if people read the book and it's like oh
this is everything that was act you know
like what some new things but you don't
want too much to change that's in the
act of interpretation basically and it
said this this is my interpretation of
James's books essentially and not just
mine actually the entire team's
basically I mean when it comes to these
characters I mean we all have our
discussions we talk about who they are
and what role they need to serve the
narrative and then I let them go I let
them do their thing and that's what
makes it feel real makes it flow
spontaneous and doesn't have this kind
of you know paint-by-numbers approach I
think that was something that was really
kind of charming about the first movie
is that there was an authenticity to it
you know there was a realness to it kind
of something something grounded about it
and I think we tried to really contain
that in this movie in a big way so Dylan
how much I mean did you feel your life
completely change overnight when you
know no I don't okay house no leave me
alone
um I want to defer to one of you guys
answer my questions for me uh Giancarlo
did Dylan's life change overnight this
guy is amazing he's like my man on set I
mean he has so much energy and so
committed to all through you you are you
really are he tumbles he jumps he runs
and he looks you right in the eye and he
plays the scene it's been one of my
favorite films to do I've been doing
this for 50 years and this cast is
committed definitely truly committed I'm
really trying Carlo the same goes for
Giancarlo by the way this is how I got
this is what I got to work with every
day it's fantastic Giancarlo what were
Rosa's motivations for play 10 Kyle look
at me I'd love to talk about some of the
new threats Wes like some of the some of
it because I know that the this world is
going to be more expansive and broad
obviously than than the last like I said
it's almost a different genre of a movie
basically and I mean one of our main
threats in this movie are these things
called the cranks and something we set
up in the first movie you start to see
that there is a virus that's kind of
infected the world is and is uh you know
ravaging this this these people of the
world and these kids are kind of
important to sort of uncovering how to
how to solve this big issue it's kind of
a big giant threat in the world
and so it was a really fun challenge to
try to visually come up with something
for these cranks these things that James
described these affected people and then
you throughout the entire movie you see
these different stages of cranks people
that are just starting to get infected
all the way to people that are really
far gone and they're pretty terrifying I
mean we have a little bit of a horror
movie on our hands here which is kind of
fun it's our new monster in this movie
it's a little bit more it's got a little
more teeth this time in fact I think we
might have something to show oh yeah
what the oh you know a lot of fans were
waiting to see these cranks and what
you're gonna see here is a little clip
that kind of shows off what the kind of
you know the really scary monsters in
our movie is
you